(intense music)
(typing)
- People who are not in STEM
kind of have an outside look
at software development,
sometimes don't understand
how truly creative it is.
Reading lines of code
is like reading poetry.
It's an art form in
itself, and it's a culture
of really bringing ideas to light.
(slow jazz music)
I started coding when I was 9 years old,
and I've been dancing since,
I think, I was able to walk.
My father is a dancer,
so it was in my blood.
So, there's one where
Mateo is on his own...
So, I had a plan in
life, I had a direction.
I was going to be a professional dancer.
Everything was lined up
and then I got cancer.
It changed the whole path of my life.
While I was in recovery,
I'm not really good at sitting still,
so I was writing software
from a hospital bed.
I'd gotten almost obsessed, like,
it was something that just kept me going.
And when I came back home,
I wanted to dance again.
I was in the midst of trying to find ways
to mix dance and technology.
And that's when I came up with
the idea of the light suits
and wirelessly programming them to make
really amazing visual art.
Alright, I'm going to stop
at this queue when it starts.
(pulsing easy techno music)
Let's just see if this is
right before they dance.
We we're up hours and hours
and hours writing this software
and trying different things.
And it was just a lot of fun.
The end product is as simple as me
pressing one button and the lights turn on
and another button and they change color.
And a few buttons and a sequence happens.
We were performing in public spaces
and the more positive reactions we got,
the more confident I
was to just go for it.
And just a few months after that,
we were on America's Got Talent,
and the rest it kind of history.
- It's ground-breaking what you do.
It’s incredible. (crowd cheers)
you create everything from
zero and it's just brilliant.
- We've worked with Chris
Brown, Death Cab for Cutie,
Christina Aguilera, Black Eyed Peas.
Then we also had our own show,
that has been in the heart
of Broadway for several years
and is touring both nationally
and internationally.
It can go on and on.
The future for iLuminate
is definitely education.
I want to be able to have students
from different backgrounds
work and collaborate together,
because if you learn how to respect people
who do something different than you
and have them respect you back,
that kind of skillset will
really take you farther in life.